your voice gets like annoying
what up everyone i'm nikki and i'm bree
and we're the best twins and we are
playing most likely drew
brie is definitely more likely to say
that is crazy because you do all the
time and it's because i'm frugal
okay
i don't like to spend a lot of money
you'll never miss that you just truly
love my style that's actually not true
no i do like your style
[Music]
i feel like you're you and i like our
twin telepathy is like is they say that
right
um said it with no confidence so that's
why it didn't sound right twin telepathy
is like
it's the same even it's the same
[Music]
both of us both of us like to work out
on vacation because it makes us feel
better about our drinking wine
drinking
wine and margaritas
well you fangirled when we saw j.lo no i
went quiet no
that's you fangirling no
um i feel like you would fangirl if you
like
were you really kate hudson in person
you would fancy i actually have met her
in person
i was on her podcast
yeah i was with you okay so i i didn't
fangirl
i'm just saying when i i was shocked
when i saw when you met you're right i
i fangirled with jlo but like i just got
really quiet and shy and i'm not shy at
all and that was that
oh for sure me i definitely your voice
gets like annoying
i'm just kidding but my voice i always
get that but i have the better voice for
power i never hear that actually people
have told me because mine's deeper it's
easier to listen to that yours can get
high in moments
hey everyone this is bree i want you to
pick my voice because i feel like it's
really deep and soothing and when it
comes to us doing our intro on the
bellas podcast usually nikki and i like
to start it by opening up a bottle of
some
delicious yummy wine nikki why don't you
describe that wine i will it's called
bonita bonito you just change your voice
like i did not in real life no
see she's a hater so we're gonna just
try to bring it to my look she won't
even let me talk cause she knows we love
to open up with a beautiful bottle of
bonita bonito wine so you have to listen
to our podcast to hear her real voice
and let us know what you think yeah
[Music]